leute wir brauchen neue ideen wie wäre
es damit nicht lachen challenge roth
das haben schon viele gemacht aber noch
kein damit facebook videos
stimmt
könnte man echt mal machen
hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen heute zu einem neuen video
ich habe letztens schon mal eine nicht
lachen channels hochgeladen habe stetig
falle ich wollte mich cool ab und die
wurde nach ein paar minuten direkt weg
ist und ich habe damit überhaupt kein
geld verdient habe das allerdings
trotzdem mega viel spaß gemacht hat und
das bei euch auch mega gut ankam habe
ich mir gedacht wir machen eine andere
nicht lachen challenge
[Musik]
[Applaus]
war
wie kann man denn so bescheuert schreien
wieder gerade geschrieben alter wartet
mal ab hört sich an erfolg
wie sieht es überhaupt aus dabei
bisher ist es so nicht so aber ich muss
lachen es ist soweit
jetzt sollen elf umgestoßen euren eltern
sondern es ist bisher halt wirklich
einfach nur so eine kombination aus
video wo man sich einfach nur so denkt
hey das ist falsch mit diesen menschen
[Musik]
und da was tut er genau das meine ich es
ist nicht so von wege hahahahaha sondern
wirklich halt mehr so
was ist falsch mit alter auf die
schnauze
fakt ist falsch könnte es gelingen
dann wirklich okay dieses kleine kinder
ist am rauchen aber dann war es nur
asthma spray trotzdem mal wieder so ein
typischer fall von höhe was wir für
menschen die da bot er hat einfach
mitten in diesem laden
dieses schild da oben komplett isoliert
bei seinem dreifachen rückwärtssalto
jeder hat mich als 8,3
da ist es genau ich als games früher ich
war immer so voll 3 ist und irgendwann
gab es einmal die szene wo meine
schwester so meinte er pack wenig sand
die hatten immer so einen sandkasten und
wir hatten da so soundso drinks gemacht
mit wasser und amüsant rein getan haben
so getan als wenn wir so cocktailmixer
irgendwann meinte meine schwester zoe du
mir nicht mehr sand nicht so
und dieses kleine kette
gebt euch dass sie dem vergleich
einverstanden er meinte irgendwie zu ihr
so erstellt das mal ganz kurz nach ihr
bruder sie ist toll aus wie cameron
dallas vornehmen wenn ich gar nicht mehr
wird aber voll häufig gesagt dass ich
aussehe wie dieser luca wendiger wer ist
das denn das bin ich weiß hat er einen
elektroschock bekommen
[Musik]
oh mein gott
[Applaus]
erfolg tut was hat sie denn für späte
reaktion ich meine die oma hat ja vorhin
ihre milch tolle da so weggeschmissen
diese katze schon relativ späte reaktion
nein der takko hat den übelsten depp
ausgepackt ihr schaut euch an der wind
und jetzt
wie beschissen sich eigentlich geradeaus
in der tat das war's
ein paar sache war lustig hermann luca
die video.de war richtig cool
dafür sollten die leute schauen mal
50.000 likes glaube die sie zusammen
kriegen 50.000 likes wenn die noch nicht
lachen stellen stehen wollen schon ein
bisschen hoch gepokert ist war voll
lustig man glaube ich was mache ich
überhaupt mit meinem leben hier
wenn euch das video gefallen hat meine
damen und herren anlass gerne mal ein
like da würde mich sehr freuen
die sind nicht lachen challenge war mal
wieder so eine kombination aus hennef
aktive menschen und lachen und einfach
nur fremdschämen ihr findet hier in zwei
die eingeblendet wenn ihr darauf könnt
ihr meinen kanal abonnieren und verpasst
keine videos mehr wer auch sehr cool da
oben findet ihr auch meinen shop
eingeblendet und hier unten
ein anderes video und wenn ihr schon
abonnent seid könnt ihr mal diese glocke
an machen weil dann verpasse keine
uploads mehr
wow